DEMOONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
DEMOGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
DEMOIC LEGISLATORS AND
DEMOOYEES MUST WE MUST LIMIT
DEMOSSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
DEMO TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
DEMO COVERING GUIDELINES AND
DEMOLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE DEMOTE HAS MADE NECESSARY
DEMOSTMENTS TO NORMAL
DEMOTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
DEMO THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
DEMO ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
DEMOESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
DEMOITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN ROOM
DEMOY TWO OH THREE AND THEN OF
OUR DEMOITTEE MEMBERS ARE
DEMOICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
IN THE DEMO FORTY TWO OH THREE
DEMO ME WILL BE SENATORS
DEMOESE DOLLY GLAZER MCGUIRE
DEMO BOOK AND PAN. TO ALLOW THE
DEMOIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
DEMOERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
DEMOING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
DEMO SOCIAL DISTANCING
DEMOIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE DEMOG A TELECONFERENCE
DEMOICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO DEMO TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
DEMOVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
DEMOIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
DEMO FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
DEMO IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
DEMOITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE DEMOEN AND I WILL
DEMOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
DEMOICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
DEMON SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE DEMO TO. AN ACCESS CODE IS
DEMO ZERO THREE ONE ONE FIVE
DEMOE. FOR DETAILED
DEMORUCTIONS ON HOW TO THE
DEMOCONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS.
DEMOSE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR DEMOITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
DEMOD TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
DEMO BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DEMO ONE THEN ZERO FOR
DEMOORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES
DEMO ONE TIME AND WAIT
DEMOENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
DEMOGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A DEMOT WAIT. WANT TO
DEMOIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
DEMO IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
DEMORATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
DEMOER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE A
NEW DID AND DEMORE NOW READY TO
DEMOESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
DEMO THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
DEMO YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
DEMOSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
DEMO THE DEVICE THAT YOU ARE
DEMOHING THE HEARING ON PARTY
DEMONG TESTIMONY OVER THE
DEMOE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
DEMO FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR DEMO PAYCHECK PATIENTS. I
DEMO MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE DEMOING AS IS CUSTOMARY M.
ANY DEMOVIDUAL WHO IS
DEMOUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE DEMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
DEMO THE CONNECTIONS MUTED.
DEMOY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
DEMOAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND DEMOUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
DEMOE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
DEMOOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
DEMO TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS.
FOR DEMOIN TO THE NEW USE OF
DEMONE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
DEMOSE BE RESPECTFUL AND
DEMOENT SO ALL INTERESTED
DEMOIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
ONE DEMOT ON TODAY'S AGENDA A.
B. ONE OH DEMO WEST SIMPLY
DEMOER GONZALEZ BEFORE WE HEAR
DEMOENTATION ON THE BILL LET'S
DEMOBLISH A CORE QUORUM. AND
DEMOULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
DEMO. SENATOR LEYVA HERE
DEMO'VE HERE OCHO A VOGUE
DEMOESE. CORTEZ A HAIR TALLY
DEMOY HERE GLAZER HERE LASER
DEMO MCGUIRE PAM. PAM HERE. WE
DEMO A QUORUM WELCOME ASSEMBLY
DEMOER PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL
DEMOK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
DEMOERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
DEMOPTING THE COMMITTEE
DEMONTINE THANK THE COMMITTEE
DEMOF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
DEMO BILL. EIGHTY ONE OH FOUR
DEMOD PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS AND
DEMOLIES WITH THE LEARNING
DEMOVERY OPPORTUNITIES THEY
DEMO TO OVERCOME THE CHALLENGES
DEMOTED BY COPA NINETEEN.
DEMOIFICALLY THE BILL PROVIDES
DEMOENTS AND FAMILIES WITH
DEMOONS THAT INCLUDE THE
DEMOITY TO PETITION FOR GRADE
DEMONTION PURSUE CREDIT
DEMOVERY OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND A
DEMOTH YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
TO DEMOEST A PASS NO PASS
DEMOON FOR GRADES ATTAINED THIS
DEMOEMIC YEAR. TO BE CLEAR
DEMONTION IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
DEMOLD BE TAKEN LIGHTLY AND
DEMOLD BE RESERVED FOR ONLY
DEMOEME CASES WHILE THE BODY
DEMOARCH IDENTIFIES RISKS WITH
DEMONTION IN NO CASE DID IT
DEMO CONCERNED THAT STUDENTS
DEMOD BE. OUT OF THE CLASSROOM
FOR AN DEMORE YEAR. OR ACTUALLY
DEMO A YEAR THIS BILL EMPLOYEES
A DEMOGHTFUL. THAT LIMITS THE
DEMOLE'S ELIGIBLE FOR RETENTION
DEMORES THAT PARENTS AND SCHOOL
DEMOF GO THROUGH A- THOROUGH
DEMOULTATION PROCESS. THAT
DEMOIDERS ALL RELEVANT
DEMORMATION AND ULTIMATELY
DEMOS THE DECISION TO RETAIN
DEMO ALLIE. SIMPLY PUT THE
DEMOULTATION PROCESS PROVIDES A
NEW WAY FOR DEMOOLS TO ENGAGE
DEMONTS AND STUDENTS ON THEIR
DEMOAL EMOTIONAL AND LEARNING
DEMOS. OF THEIR STUDENTS FOR
THE DEMOON TO RETAIN MASSIMO
DEMOIVE TARGETED SUPPLEMENTAL
DEMOORT AND INSTRUCTION AS
DEMORED UNDER AB EIGHTY SIX.
DEMOONS OFTEN OFFERED UNDER
DEMO BILL WHEN SURE THAT
DEMOENTS AND PARENTS. IN
DEMOLIES- IN A DRESSER LEARNING
DEMO AND ARE HELD HARMLESS
DEMON WHAT THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH
DEMO PAST YEAR. IT HAS AN
DEMOGENCY CLAUSE IT HAS
DEMOIVED BROAD BIPARTISAN
DEMOORT NO NO WORKS AND I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
DEMOK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER OF WE
DEMO NO LEAD SUPPORT SO WE'RE
DEMOA GO TO SUPPORT HERE IN
DEMOY TWO OH THREE SEEING NONE
DEMO GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
DEMONG NONE. A MODERATOR CAN
YOU DEMOE UP ANYONE WHO'S IN
DEMOORT OF AB ONE OH FOUR.
DEMOK YOU MADAM CHAIR ANYONE
WHO DEMOES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
DEMOSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
DEMO TIME PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
WE DEMO ONE PERSON WHO SIGNALED
DEMO THEY WISH TO SPEAK LINE
DEMOVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
DEMOE Q. ME I'M AN OPPOSITION.
DEMO NOT A PROBLEM WE WILL GET
TO YOU DEMOTLY. SORRY MR
DEMORATED WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
WHO DEMOD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
DEMOORT OF A B. ONE OH FOUR.
DEMO A MOMENT. THE MANAGER JUST
A DEMONT PLACE UP NO PROBLEM.
WE DO DEMO ONE PERSON THAT
DEMOALED THAT THEY WISH TO
DEMOK JUST A MOMENT. HEY WE'RE
DEMOA GO TO LINE A TEN BY TEN
TO ONE IS DEMO. ONE CAN YOUR
DEMO IS NOW OPEN. HELLO HELLO.
DEMO LINE IS OPEN. I'M IN
DEMOSITION CAN YOU RE QUEUE ME
DEMOSE OKAY NO PROBLEM MISS
DEMORATOR IT APPEARS WE HAVE NO
ONE DEMOD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
DEMOORT SO WE WILL NOW GO TO WE
DEMO NO LEAD OPPOSITION WE WILL
GO TO DEMO FORTY TWO OH THREE
FOR ANY DEMOSITION SEEING MAN
DEMO GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
DEMONG NONE NOW WILL GO TO
DEMONE ON THE PHONE LINES WHO
DEMOD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
DEMOSITION. OF AB ONE OH FOUR
DEMO STATE YOUR NAME AND THAT
YOU ARE DEMOSED. FOR THOSE OF
YOU DEMO WISH TO SPEAK IN
DEMOSITION- EVEN IF YOU SIGNAL
BUT DEMO YOU'RE MY WAS
DEMOIOUSLY OPEN WE NEED YOU TO
DEMOS ONE ZERO. I WILL BE ABLE
TO LET YOU DEMOK PRESS. ONE
DEMO ZERO. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
DEMO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M ONE DEMOVE AND YOU HAVE NO
DEMO OPPOSITION AND I'M OING
TO DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
DEMORTUNITY TO READ A BRIEF
DEMOEMENT IN OPPOSITION THE
DEMOR IS STARTED GO AHEAD YOU
DEMO TWO MINUTES. I AM CALLING
DEMOY TO EXPRESS MY OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE OH DEMO AS WELL AS TO
DEMOY SOME TESTIMONY GIVEN BY
DEMOION FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEMONCE. IN ASSEMBLY
DEMOOPRIATIONS ON MAY SEVENTH
DEMORDING A B. ONE OH FOUR
DEMOUM TESTIFIED THAT EIGHTY
ONE OH DEMO CREATE SIGNIFICANT
DEMOL COSTS. AND A REIMBURSABLE
DEMOE MANDATE IN THE HUNDREDS
OF DEMOIONS OF DOLLARS
DEMOOSITION NINETY EIGHT
DEMORAL FUND BY REQUIRING ALL
ONE DEMOSAND AND THIRTY SEVEN
DEMOFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO
DEMOT A NEW RETENTION POLICY
AND TO DEMOIDE APPROPRIATE
DEMOCE TO STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
DEMONDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
DEMORICT. COSTS COULD RANGE
DEMO ONE THOUSAND TO ONE
DEMORED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
DEMOOL DISTRICT THE FOUR
DEMORED AND TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL
DEMORICTS SERVING STUDENTS IN
DEMOES. NINE TO TWELVE MUST
DEMO ADOPT NEW POLICIES AROUND
DEMOT CHANGES AND PROVIDE
DEMONDED OPPORTUNITIES TO
DEMOENTS NOT ON TRACK TO
DEMOUATE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
DEMO AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
DEMOOL YEARS THESE COSTS COULD
DEMOE FROM FIVE THOUSAND TO
DEMO HUNDRED THOUSAND PER
DEMOOL DISTRICT OR MORE
DEMONDING ON THE OPPORTUNITIES
DEMOIDED IN THE STUDENT NUMBER
DEMOENT DO YOU LIKE UTILIZING
DEMO. TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
DEMO INCREASES THE NUMBER OF
DEMO SCHOOL STUDENTS
DEMOICIPATING IN THE FIFTH YEAR
OF DEMORUCTION THIS BILL COULD
DEMOEASE LOCAL. CONTROL FUNDING
DEMOULA COSTS ADDITIONALLY THE
DEMOFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
DEMOATION WILL HAVE AN
DEMOMATED ONE TIME COST OF
DEMOOXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
DEMOY THOUSAND DOLLARS. NON
DEMOOSITION NINETY FIVE GENERAL
DEMO TO DEVELOP AN APPLICATION
FOR DEMOE CHANGES FOR USE BY
DEMOL EDUCATION AGENCIES AND TO
DEMOLOP AND POST A LIST OF POST
DEMONDARY INSTITUTIONS. THAT
DEMO INDICATED THAT THEY WILL
DEMOPT PASSPORT CREDIT FOR
DEMOSSION PURPOSES. BELIEVE ME
I DO NOT IN ANY WAY DEMOK THAT
DEMODREN SHOULD BE HARMED. BY
THE BY THE DEMOCT DUE TO SCHOOL
DEMOURES FROM THE PANDEMIC WHAT
DEMO BILL AB ONE OH FOUR IS NOT
THE WAY TO DEMOIR THE DAMAGE%
DEMO YOU LEGISLATORS HAVE DONE
TO THE DEMODREN. AND IT IS JUST
DEMO GOVERNMENT. NONSENSE PLUS
IF WE DEMOA GONZALEZ REALLY
DEMOT. SHE WOULD NOT HAVE COME
DEMOORED SB TWO SUB SIX AND SHE
DEMOD NOT HAVE BECAUSE SO MANY
DEMONTS WOULD BE OUT OF WORK
DEMO EIGHTY FIVE. I COULD GO ON
AND ON BUT YOU GET IT DEMO THIS
DEMO. GARBAGE GOVERNMENT OVER
DEMOH AND LORRAINE A VIRTUE
DEMOALING HERSELF. ALMOST AS
BAD AS DEMOLING LIP LOCK. GREAT
DEMOK YOU SO MUCH OKAY WE WILL
NOW DEMO ON BRING IT BACK TO
THE DEMOITTEE DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANY DEMOENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
DEMO HAS BEEN MOVED SENATOR
DEMOESE SO I JUST WANT TO THINK
OF THE DEMOOR FOR LEADERSHIP ON
DEMO THIS IS BEEN A HUGE HUGE
DEMOE ESPECIALLY AT THE
DEMONDARY LEVEL- IN MY DISTRICT
IN. A LOT OF DEMOLE ARE
DEMOOUSLY WAITING FOR THE
DEMOMENT OF THE SPILL THANK YOU.
DEMOK YOU CENTER CORTESE ANYONE
DEMO YES SEND OUT LIKE. THIS
ONE IS I DEMO LIKE TO ADD TO
THE DEMOON SERVICE CENTRE
DEMOESE THIS GIVES PARENTS AN
DEMOON TO DO THE RIGHT THING
FOR DEMOR CHILDREN APPRECIATE
YOU DEMOG THE BILL FOR. VERY
DEMO THANK YOU YES SANDER VAN
DEMO I JUST WANT TO- TO EXPRESS
MY DEMOKS TO THE AUTHOR FOR HER
DEMOCACY FOR CHILDREN AND THE
DEMOTY OF OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN
DEMO I THINK THAT'S- A PRETTY
DEMOED- HER CONTINUED EFFORTS
IN DEMOG THAT. AND- SO THANK
DEMO SENATOR GLAZER YEAH JUST
ADD DEMO- I THINK WITH THE MOST
DEMORTANT THAT. NO DNA ANALYSIS
IS DEMO THIS IS A SUPPLEMENTAL
TO DEMOTING RETENTION RULES AND
NOT A DEMOACEMENT SO FOR OUR
DEMOOL BOARD MEMBERS OUT THERE
WHO DEMO ALSO IN TRYING TIMES
AS A ALL OF US AND OUR AND OUR
DEMOENT COMMUNITY JUST TO NOTE%
DEMO THAT THIS IS A POSITIVE
DEMO OPPORTUNITY THAT I
DEMOECIATED THE BILL HAPPY TO
DEMOORT THANK YOU SENATOR
DEMOER ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU DEMO TO CLOSE. INTEL YOU
DEMO I'VE SPENT THE LAST YEAR
DEMO WITH THREE KIDS- IN FOURTH
DEMOE SEVENTH GRADE AND A
DEMOOR IN HIGH SCHOOL. AND
DEMOOUGH MY SENIOR WILL GO ON
AND HE WAS DEMO THERE ARE A LOT
OF DEMOLENGES AND I REALIZE
DEMO MY LITTLE MOM GROUP HOW
DEMO CHALLENGES IN DIFFERENT
DEMOLENGES UNIQUE CHALLENGES
PER DEMOENT PER PARENT WE'RE
DEMO TRYING TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
AND DEMONTS MORE CHOICES AND
DEMOIDE THEM SOME FLEXIBILITY-
TO DEMORE. THAT THEY'RE HELD
DEMOLESS FROM THIS PAST YEAR SO
I DEMO TO NOTE DESPITE. I DON'T
DEMO HOW SERIOUSLY I TAKE THE
DEMOSITION I WENT OUT SHE WAS
DEMOING THE ASSEMBLY
DEMOOPRIATIONS- ANALYSIS IN
DEMO THIS BILL HAS BEEN.
DEMOTICALLY CHANGE AS FAR AS
THE DEMONTION POLICY AND THE
DEMO ON THE ON THE RETENTION
DEMOCY AND SO WITH THAT I
DEMOECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
DEMOK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK-YOU AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH THE
DEMOITTEE I THINK WE I REALLY
DEMOTED SOMETHING GOOD SO THANK
YOU DEMOM CONSULTANT PLEASE
DEMO THE ROLL WE HAVE A MOTION
BY DEMOTOR DOLLY PLEASE CALL
THE DEMO. BY LET HIM NUMBER ONE
A. B. ONE OH DEMO THE MOTION IS
TO DEMO AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
DEMOD AND RE REFERRED TO THE
DEMOITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
DEMOTOR LEYVA BY LEVI OCHO
DEMOE HI A TROUBLE GUY
DEMOTESY. COURTESY I DELI DELI
I DEMOER HI PLEASE R. I.
DEMOIRE. PAN HI AN HIGH. THE
DEMO GOOD THAT THE OUT THANK
YOU DEMO MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
DEMOERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEMOK YOU TO ALL THE
DEMOVIDUALS THE ONE WHO
DEMOICIPATED IN PUBLIC
DEMOIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT DEMO TO TESTIFY TODAY
DEMOSE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
DEMOESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
DEMOTE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
DEMOT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND DEMOESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE DEMO TO INCLUDE
DEMO TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
DEMOING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE DEMOECIATE YOUR-
DEMOICIPATION. THANK YOU FOR
DEMOYONE YOUR PATIENTS WE HAVE
DEMOLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
DEMOITTEE ON EDUCATION IS
DEMOURNED.